-The House impeachment managers
have presented a damning
and powerful case
against former president
Donald Trump this week,
including harrowing new scenes
of violence
from the Capitol riot and never-
before-seen security footage
of lawmakers being rushed away
from the mob.
The evidence makes clear that
the attack was much worse
than we knew, that it could have
been even worse than it was,
and that it was directed
explicitly by Trump,
and yet Republicans have made
clear they just don't care.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
The thing about Donald Trump
is that it's always clear
exactly who he has been
since day one of his campaign.
There was no confusion.
It's like when the great
Michael Shannon
pops up in a movie,
you immediately know
he's the bad guy.
Michael Shannon's not there
to rescue puppies
or provide sage advice
to newlyweds.
He's there to steal his father's
inheritance or kill Superman.
Or maybe he's starring
in a Ted Cruz biopic.
It's hard to tell.
Anyway, everyone knew
what Trump was about
and what his movement was about.
He tapped into something ugly
and horrifying
at the heart of the modern
Republican Party,
and the threat
of political violence
played a central role in that.
He repeatedly encouraged his
supporters to physically attack
protesters and promised to pay
their legal bills,
which we know now,
of course, was a lie.
I mean, he can't even pay
his own legal bills.
He stiffed Rudy, the one lawyer
who was willing to defend Trump
by flying cross-country
and lying about the election,
finding witnesses
outside package stores,
and holding press conferences
and also, I'm guessing, sleeping
at landscaping companies.
[ As Giuliani ]
Oh, no need for a cot.
I'll just curl up in the mulch!
[ Normal voice ] Plus,
forget paying for them --
based on his lawyers,
would you really want
Donald Trump picking yours?
I'm starting to think
he buys his in bulk
at Bob's Partially Damaged
Lawyers Discount Basement.
"This one's good
on the Constitution,
but he craps himself every time
he hears the word 'objection.'"
"Can I get that one
in a suit that fits?"
"No, everything here is as is."
"Can I get that one
with a briefcase
instead of a grocery bag?"
"As is!"
And not only has it been clear
who Trump was from day one,
but the people who publicly
warned us about him
are now his strongest
supporters.
-Presidents can't just say
whatever they want.
There are consequences
to the words of a president.
to the words
of a presidential candidate,
as well.
You have a candidate
in Donald Trump
who clearly has used language
that appeals to anger
and in some instances has
actually said to the crowd,
"No, let's beat this person up"
and let's do this
or let's do that.
So it shouldn't surprise us that
you see a growing amount
of violence
at some of his events.
There's only one
presidential candidate
who has violence
at their events.
-Ooh, ooh, wait, wait!
Can I guess who it is?
Uh...I don't think
it's John Kasich,
unless he was bullying
his supporters into
signing up with TD Ameritrade.
Certainly, it couldn't
have been Bernie.
I'm guessing the closest
Bernie comes to violence
is using a firm tone when
somebody mixes up
the Bosc and Bartlett pears
at the Burlington food co-op.
[ As Sanders ]
You have to keep them separate.
One is crisp
and the other is sweet.
If I see you mixing them up
again, I'll have no choice
but to gently clap your ears
with my adorable mittens.
[ Normal voice ] In fact, this
is the most violent thing
I believe Bernie has ever said
in his life.
-You know, I eat extra sharp.
That's what I eat.
You know, they produce
great cheese
and they're internationally
known for what they do.
-That's right, Bernie's cheese
is extra sharp,
just like his tongue.
Anyway, Marco Rubio predicted
this five years ago.
In fact, his vision of what
a Trump presidency would be like
was eerily accurate.
-The great thing about
our Republic is that
we settle our differences in
this country at the ballot box,
not with guns or
bayonets or violence.
And you wonder whether we're
headed in a different direction
today, where we're no longer
able or capable of having
differences of opinion,
but in fact,
now protests become a license
to take violence,
to take on your opponents
physically.
This is what happens when
a leading presidential candidate
goes around feeding into
a narrative of anger
and bitterness and frustration,
and I think we all need to take
a step back and ask ourselves,
are we contributing to this?
-Well, did you ask yourself?
Or are you still taking
steps back five years later,
which would put you almost
into international waters?
So, that was Rubio
all the way back in 2016 --
you know, back when he went by
"Little Marco."
He's all grown up now!
But in that clip,
Marco is basically laying out
the same argument
Democrats are making today.
In fact, he's passionate
about it.
And yet despite there being
more evidence
that Rubio was right then,
he and his gang
have instead actively chosen
to collude with evil
and abandon whatever they may
have believed about Donald Trump
five years ago
in order to advance
their political careers
and obtain power.
Which is how -- fast-forward
five years -- you get this.
-This impeachment trial,
let me ask you,
how many people are gonna get
vaccinated because of this
impeachment trial?
None.
How many people
are gonna find a job
because of this
impeachment trial?
None.
How many people
are gonna be helped
to put their kids back in school
because of this
impeachment trial?
None.
We are going to spend a week
focused on something
that is not going to help anyone
with the thing that matters
in this country the most
right now.
And that's a terrible thing.
That's a waste of our time.
-Ask yourself, how many people
are gonna get superpowers
from this impeachment trial?
None.
How many people are gonna
fall in love because of this
impeachment trial?
None.
How many people are gonna win
the McDonald's Monopoly
million-dollar grand prize
by collecting all four railroads
from containers of large
or medium-size fries
or McFlurries or apple pies?
None.
Because you can't get the
railroads from the apple pies,
even though they're one of
the most popular menu items.
You have to buy the McNuggets,
the Big Mac or the Filet-O-Fish,
even though no one wants the
Filet-O-Fish because it tastes
like deep-fried cat food.
And God forbid
you leave a Filet-O-Fish
in your car overnight --
that's it for that car.
Nobody will even tow it for you.
What I'm saying is,
Impeachment is a waste of time.
But that's not
what impeachment is for.
You should be capable of doing
two or three
or even, God forbid,
four things at once.
If you really want to help
people out,
why not sign on to
the Democrats' COVID relief bill
or a $15 minimum wage?
If you care so much about the
pandemic or poverty
or child hunger, where were you
when the previous president
was shoveling trillions
into the pockets of rich people
and corporations
and telling everyone COVID would
magically disappear
so long as they stick a few
Tide to Go pens up their noses?
Why didn't you say anything?
Why did you spend four years
cryptically tweeting
Bible quotes
like some kind of serial killer
or a Southern
chicken restaurant?
Because you're a boneless fraud
who dresses less like a senator
and more like an assistant
high school basketball coach
who gets fired for stealing
towels from the locker room.
Seriously, dude,
did you win that hat
in a local radio station contest
by calling in and guessing
the number-one hit
in March 1995?
You look like you got
your entire outfit
from a T-shirt cannon fired by
the Phoenix Suns gorilla.
Also, does your hat
match your chair?
Because that's weird.
Don't do that.
And then this morning,
a grown-up Marco decided
to wear a big-boy suit,
go on "Fox & Friends,"
and once again dismiss
the trial,
the harrowing scenes of violence
and the never-before-seen
security footage
as a waste of time.
-They spent a lot of time
yesterday convincing us
of what I already knew
and believed, and that is
that the attack on January 6th
was outrageous,
criminal, deadly.
It could have been far worse.
I knew that, as well.
So I don't think there's any
dispute about that.
The question is whether
impeachment, which is designed
clearly to remove someone from
office, is the appropriate thing
to do when someone
is no longer in office.
And my answer to that is no.
-Oh, man, if only
current Marco Rubio
could meet 2016 Marco Rubio.
It would be like a sci-fi movie
where you have to choose
between two clones,
except they both suck
because they in turn are clones
of the third clone
who also sucked.
Also, that's not actually what
impeachment is designed for.
The framers were clear
about this.
The Constitution explicitly
gives the Senate the power
to bar someone from ever holding
public office again.
In fact, as we speak,
Trump is also under criminal
investigation in Georgia
for trying to steal
the election.
And if you ask me, inciting
a violent, seditious mob
to storm the Capitol where they
went after the vice president,
the speaker of the house,
and members of Congress,
and where they injured
140 police officers
sounds like pretty good reason
to be barred from public office.
I mean, you can get barred
from Hooters
for not wearing a shirt
and shoes.
Place is named after
bare breasts,
and you still have to
wear a shirt.
We've all seen the damning
video footage this week.
It's haunting.
And yet the Republican Party
and its media apparatus
aren't just looking
the other way metaphorically --
they're looking away literally.
Rubio, along with a few other
GOP senators,
reportedly looked down
at some papers
as the harrowing footage played.
There was also previously unseen
camera footage
of vice President Mike Pence
and Senator Mitt Romney
being rushed away
from the mob to safety.
We learned that House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi had to be evacuated
from the entire Capitol complex
for her safety.
At least show some concern
for the physical safety
of your colleagues.
If someone showed me a hostage
video of my friend Fred Armisen
waving to get my attention
because he was being
held captive in a room
by kidnappers,
I wouldn't just ignore it
and move on.
Uh, not now, Fred.
And then there's Missouri
Senator Josh Hawley,
the guy who got kicked out of
Cobra Kai for being too slimy
and then wrote an op-ed titled
"How I Got Cobra Kaincelled."
Hawley not only ignored
the harrowing video footage,
but made himself comfortable
while doing it.
-Josh Hawley, who's made his
disdain for this process
abundantly clear
in public comments,
was doing the same
thing in the chamber.
All of the senators have
the option to use the gallery,
the upstairs area for seating
for social distancing.
Josh Hawley is the only one
taking advantage
of that opportunity.
He's been sitting
with his legs up on the seat
in front of him
essentially reading
non-related material.
-Of course he was.
Hawley is the richest kid
in high school
who during the memorial assembly
for the beloved librarian
loudly comments on the "Playboy"
hidden in his science book.
"We will all miss
Debra's love of reading."
"Yowza, Joshy like!"
And then there was Fox News,
which actually had the gall
to cut away from the trial
in the middle
of the harrowing testimony
to get to Jesse Watters
and Jeanine Pirro.
-You may have heard one man
yelled, "No violence,"
and another responded,
"It's too late for that."
♪♪
-Hello, everybody,
I'm Jesse Watters,
along with Juan Williams,
Dana Perino,
Greg Gutfeld,
and Judge Jeanine Pirro.
-That's right, they cut off
the impeachment trial.
Usually, these two are the ones
getting cut off.
At any time,
you could ask Jesse Watters
to blow into a breathalyzer
and the result would probably
just say "Natty Light."
And I'm sure Jeanine's
been kicked out
of her share of Applebee's.
"Alright, Jeanine,
you've had enough."
"How dare you take away my keys!
According to the Constitution,
I'm entitled
to as many Long Island iced teas
as I want!"
And what was so urgent Fox News
felt justified in cutting away
from the historic impeachment
trial of a former president
who incited
a violent insurrection?
What could possibly have been
more important
than the sanctity
of our democracy?
-"Special Report" is up next
with Bret.
-Jesse, I'm here, I just can't
seem to get rid of this filter.
Um, I'm here, though.
I'm -- I'm not a bear.
[ Laughter ]
-I have to say,
even in that screen shot,
Jesse Watters still has
the dumber face.
Leave it to Fox News
to ruin a fun meme.
Can't we have fun things?
This is like your dad singing
the lyrics to "WAP."
But before they could get
to the urgent meme content,
the five spent time exploding at
each other in an insane argument
after Juan Williams correctly
accused the rest of the panel
of ignoring
the impeachment trial.
-This impeachment trial that
you guys are all ignoring,
I guess you're afraid of it
because it's a reminder --
-Don't mind-read, Juan.
Please don't mind-read.
-Juan, we talked about it
for 10 minutes!
-Don't mind-read.
-Let me finish! Nah, nah, nah!
-Don't mind-read, then!
-You guys had all the time --
-Don't read my mind, Juan.
-There's no need!
-There's no need, 'cause
I listened to all of this!
So, let me tell you what --
-Then how can you be so wrong?
-What I heard was --
-How could you be so wrong?
If you listened,
how can you be so wrong?
-This trial to me is about
whether or not Republicans --
-Hey, Juan.
-...want to close their eyes --
-Hey, Juan. Hold on.
-Or they want to face the truth.
And right now, let me tell you,
let me tell you,
facing the truth
is the way that we solve this,
the way we bring the country
together.
Ignoring problems is never
the way to solve a problem.
-You shouldn't be impugning
our intentions, Juan.
That's the problem.
-That's right.
-I hope you didn't say we are
standing with these people.
-I don't need to intuit it.
I can listen.
I can hear you guys.
-And don't tell me who
to stand with, either.
-Then it goes into your brain
and it comes out wrong.
-Ah, that is some
high-Level debate.
I can't see without my glasses.
Is that Lincoln and Douglas?
"A house divided against itself
cannot stand."
"That's not what I said,
Lincoln!"
"Yeah, it is, Douglas."
"No, it's not! The words are
going into your brain
and coming out
of your mouth wrong."
"Oh, yeah? Well, if the words
are coming into my brain,
they're coming out of your ass!"
"Well, then I guess that means
you're eating my ass words,
Douglas."
"That's not what I said.
Don't read my mind.
I can feel you reading my mind,
and I don't want you in there.
Get out of my mind, Lincoln!"
It's been clear from the start
who Trump was
and what he stood for.
Republicans knew it then,
and they know it now.
They made the same case
Democrats are making now.
They saw it,
they warned us about it,
and then they capitulated.
And that's because they share
Trump's goals.
They're engaged
in the same project.
They agree with him.
They saw that supporting him
was the path to power
and they jumped on board.
And they're willing to look away
from any piece of evidence
or tell any lie necessary
to expunge their guilt,
with one exception.
There was one instance
yesterday on Fox News
where someone bravely stood up
and told the truth.
-I'm not a bear.
-Thank you.
This has been "A Closer Look."
Gods Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe, wash your hands,
wear a mask. We love you.